all right we are here with the one the
only Trixie Mattel now a cosmetics
entrepreneur God cancel me cancel expose
me on YouTube I'm a I'm a makeup mogul
you're surviving and thriving at drag
con with one of the longest lines here
it might be an artist and it might be a
woman but I'm primarily a capitalist so
if you tell me people who are gonna buy
stuff are gonna be in a centralized
location I will come here and I will
bring things to sell and I saw you
interacting with children which I know
is not your favorite no I could just I
was gritting my teeth were grinding so
hard that that girl stepped away and I
think I actually broke one of my crowns
but as we know I have an extra crown at
home yeah you had you had quite the
entrance during the winners walk what is
it I'd like to make a splash and if
you're gonna sell cosmetics you have to
go big and you have to go big bye
what better way to tell people you're
selling lipstick than to show up on a
giant lipstick are you ready to see
something are you ready to see something
yes please
my god should have ever given me TV
money like I was one of those people
should have never had money to play with
because this is it that's what I do how
much did this cost this sorted topic of
coin wouldn't want to talk about that I
will say it cost 25 cents every time I
want to use it because it's built on a
real machine I have to have quarters so
I just rely on the kindness of strangers
but where does this go on to live after
drag con well what's funny is I have
parking spots at my condo but no car so
I will have this in one parking space
and in the other parking space I have my
Barbie Jeep from last year and I'm a 29
year old man so anyone wanted to know
where Trixie lives just look out for
those two things yeah I don't really
think things through and then I have
stuff like I just taped my special on
Thursday now I have giant letters that
light up and say Trixie I guess those
are going to my house I don't know you
are conquering it all we got a special a
documentary we've got yellow cloud out
makeup out what is untapped for Trixie
oh my god breast breast forms well you
know Ruth handler the woman who invented
Barbie she went on to become somebody
who created lifelike breast forms for
cancer survivors so maybe I'll somehow
someday parlay this into a philanthropic
effort putting makeup on people okay
like I have a bunch of extra Red Bull in
my house and I was gonna donate it to a
women's shelter
but then I was like well the last thing
somebody in like who's a homeless woman
might need is like a sugar rush the
crash later so I'm doing some cool stuff
like this year with the cosmetics we're
partnering with the honeybee Conservancy
and so we're donating money from the
cell of the sales of the cosmetics to
preserve honeybees okay giving back the
honey and yes you are right next door to
your sister and drag Katia and look it
up you can tell I bring a lot to the
table I have a pink carpet I have a
lipstick you can ride and she has a
tapestry of Julia Roberts so it tracks
it tracks it totally tracks but I know
in the documentary you get into kind of
thinking that creative partnership
might have ended yeah what was it like
to share that with the world well just
like drag or sobriety or friendship
nothing has ever a straight road and so
it was uh it's weird to watch back
because it was so dark for a while but
in a film that's an hour in 30 minutes
you know 40 minutes in time moves fast
everything's resolved I learned a lot
from that friendship and from anything
you know anything this career you know I
was afraid at one point that Sonny and
Cher would have to become just Cher but
that day is not here yet she's well
she's much older than me so that date
that day will come but yeah this is kind
of like the big party before the season
11 finale airs on Thursday who are you
rooting for in that finale well I know
it's like well if you look at the track
record you have a thing who's done the
best this season who has the biggest fan
following you know and I think that the
true winner Tammy Brown always you turn
Tammy Brown into a video ho completely
she's in yellow cloud I gotta tell you
if you guys watch the video she's in it
and she never takes a break so we filmed
for six hours probably and she's in that
TV stand and I'm like are you okay it's
just like I'm fine she never took a
break a true professional sessional yes
well I will let you get back to your
professional work here teenagers are
gonna tackle you if you make em waiting
I'm like I'm meeting up too much time
for these 13-year old walk that way
you're gonna do the stink-eye from some
seventh grader I am gonna force you to
take a photo with me though first
because I am a fan too
all right here we go
perfect Thank You Trixie good to see you
see you at the next family reunion